hablemos primero del significado de la
llegada de castillo no al poder
candidato de lo que es considerado el
perú rural verdad que llega a
supuestamente a romper con los símbolos
tradicionales y coloniales como lo
caracterizaría y que podríamos esperar
de su gestión
distancia el segundo término quizás la
frase que más se te pueda acomodar a
pedro castillo está pronunciada el día
de hoy en su juramentación por la
vicepresidenta del inah baluarte es el
presidente de los nadies justamente esta
parte rural del pib del perú que vota
diferente a lo que vota la capital de
lima y que obviamente tiene demandas
diferentes muy bien muy distantes a este
crecimiento económico que ha que se ha
visto en lima y en las principales
provincias de la zona de la costa
castillo representa lo que es la zona
rural el ande y parte de la selva en
esta perspectiva de nuevas metas y
nuevos cierre de brechas para poder
tener equidad social y justicia en todo
el perú ahora algo de lo que hablo
castellano en su primer discurso con
nuevo presidente de perú tiene que ver
con una convención constituyente que
estaría encargada de redactar una nueva
constitución faltan todavía varios
procesos no como un referendo por
ejemplo al que hizo referencia cree
usted que esto es viable en un escenario
con dificultades para
como es perú
efectivamente la forma en que nos está
presentando esta asamblea constituyente
pero castillo es a través de una vía
netamente constitucional es decir
presentar un proyecto de ley al congreso
de la república quien lo debatirá si es
del caso lo aprobará y si es que tiene
la mayoría de dos tercios es decir 87
votos podrá pasar a una segunda
legislatura lo que él está esperando es
que solamente tenga aprobación de una
mayoría simple y pueda ir a referéndum y
que la ciudadanía se manifieste sobre la
posibilidad de modificar la constitución
para que exista una asamblea
constituyente y así se pueda redactar
una nueva constitución es la alternativa
que ha ideado pero castillo en ese
sentido vamos a ver si es que la fuerza
y la nueva correlación de fuerzas que
hay en el congreso de la república le da
para poder desarrollar esta idea